moi je voudrais revenir sur le 100 %
contrôle de Guyane puisque la madame la
procureur du tribunal judiciaire de
pointapit en a parlé tout à l'heure mais
moi ma question c'est de savoir
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous je
m'adresse aux deux procureurs procureur
de poapite et de Fort de- France et si
vous vous avz est-ce que vous vous avez
une proposition pour qu'on arrive à à
justement puisquon a bien vu que il y a
un changement de route puisque les mules
émigrent vers la Martinique la
Guadeloupe euh moi j'aimerais savoir si
vous vous auriez des idées parce que
franchement chez nous en Guyane c'est un
fléo j'ai pas l'impression
personnellementin que les 100 %
contrôles réduisent tant que ça les
mules puisque il y a quand même des
voyageurs qui qui subissent ses arrêtés
préfect tourau donc qui qui les
empêchent de voyager pendant 6 mois mais
je pense qu'il renouvelle et
recommenence donc ça dissuade pas
vraiment donc ma question c'était de
savoir si vous en tant que procureur
vous auriez des idées pour des
propositions de dispositifs sur le 100 %
contrôle je partage l'avis du membre de
votre commission effectivement je suis
pas sûre que ce soit très utile
puisqu'on sait que lorsque on annonce
des contrôles sur les vols on a 30
personnes qui ne prennent pas l'avion
mais on en a quand même 10 mul qui le
prennent donc soit elles n'ont pas eu le
bon SMS soit elles n'avaient pas le bon
téléphone soit elles ne savent pas lire
en tout cas euh
ça met euh certainement ça limite le
trafic mais ça n'est pas suffisant et
puis de toute façon les trafics se
détourne 100 % contrôle alors là moi
pour le coup je suis pas forcément
d'accord moi j'ai l'impression quand
même que grâce à la mise en place 100 %
contrôle ça a permis de déterminer
l'ampleur du trafic de de stupéfiant
parce que on avait pas forcément
conscience de l'ampleur du du niveau de
cocaïne qui partait vers la métropole
depuis la Guyane donc moi je pense que
quand même ça a permis déjà de freiner
et de ralentir le le de freiner les
mules après ça les a effectivement en
partie détourné nous on ne pourra pas
alors là à un moment en Guadeloupe c'est
justement quand on a commencé à en
parler a été évoqué l'idée de est-ce
qu'il ne faudrait pas aussi faire du 100
% contrôle mais pourquoi pas enfin moi
je suis ouverte à tout la difficulté
c'est qu'il y a pas les moyens je pense
qu'il n'y a pas les moyens et c'est ce
que m'ont dit les douiniers aussi hein
c'est qu'ils peuvent pas ils ont pas les
moyens pour contrôler de toute façon
pour faire du 100 % contrôle sur tous
les départs vers vers la métropole mais
à un moment il faudrait s'y mettre mais
c'est ça nécessite surtout de travailler
en amont et je comprends parfaitement la
difficulté de la limitation des moyens
de de travailler en amont sur les
trafics il y a aussi les mules sont
finalement des personnes très
vulnérables que ça soit des guyanés
comme en ce moment des des Nigériens qui
finalement ont trouvé ce système là pour
pouvoir et on voit qu'il y en a certains
qui font vraiment beaucoup de voyage
donc au risque de leur propre vie et
nous ce qui nous intéresse et on
aimerait vraiment pouvoir remonter le
plus haut possible des trafic pour
justement les démanteler et pour savoir
qui a intérêt à ce trafic et qui en
profite surtout voilà mais ce 100 %
contrôle moi je trouve que au moins il a
permis de mettre en lumière l'ampleur
des départs bourré de cocaïne vers la
métropole mais je pense surtout que là
où il faut encore plus accentuer le
contrôle c'est sur le maritime dans les
containers et là je je je pense qu'on
est pas suffisamment outiller sur ces
contrôles maritimes on a peut-être
renforcé sur l'aérien on a bloqué en
tout cas certains certains contrôles
grâce à certains contrôles sur l'aérien
mais pas suffisamment sur le mar sur la
sur le maritime